[Music]
hey babe hi
you go through a purple without texting
each other look at that purple nurple
Purple Rain
oh my God look at that wait a minute did
you suggest this song because I was
wearing this shirt it must have been I
didn't even know
look up to me you said what about Little
Red Corvette and I said a little red hey
babe wow but you you did not know I was
wearing this I swear to God I did it wow
see that's that's
what you think about the human mind is
we don't we don't even realize that and
I just sang that I forgot I forgot that
I was wearing the shirt because you know
what I've heard I've I I've people are
talking about this now people are not
talking no that's not a song you don't
know a lot of times you don't know what
I'm saying a lot of time I'm gonna be
honest with you I'm gonna be completely
honest with you I don't know much about
music and I don't know much about comedy
don't know much about
his story don't know much
biography you know this is I I I but I
do know that I love you and if you say
that you love me to what a wonderful
world world this it's Sam Cook
I don't even know who Sam Cooke is
before what I said people are not
talking what song do you think that is I
I honestly thought you were singing
let's give them something I was oh that
is yeah okay
oh I don't know who it is Bonnie Ray
Reba McIntyre yeah Chris Stapleton
um what's the kid Oliver who's the kitty
blew up I know you mean Oliver tree what
is it
uh he's a kid I'm seeing everywhere um
Joe Rogan played his song and it's got a
song
man north of Richmond so uh
yeah yeah so he's uh
I went on it was it was like uh I just
started seeing them every I I'm gonna
listen to the song too I've heard it's a
great song capital of Virginia I cut you
off earlier you make a sentiment okay so
when I wanted to say was
as Marcus Aurelius said as we spoke
about as we always speak about the
stoics he said never be overheard
complaining not even to yourself and I
think about that every day do not
complain but today my friend I gotta
complain today Marcus Aurelius is a race
from the books listen Marcus Aurelius
here's the thing I like what you've
teached but you're dead so shut up okay
you're dead shut up I am tired I'm
irritable I and I want to preemptively
apologize for first of all I walked in
here Eric Andre was walking out gonna be
a great episode on taste buds Eric Andre
kind kid never even really met him I I I
looked at him he said something to me I
was just in such a mood that I just gave
no expression I I feel terrible because
I was like why did I he's such a nice
man that he's that smells you know okay
and I was like I was like why why did I
do that and then I said you know what
Chris I said you got to take a minute I
said I made a decision when I walked in
this Studio I said I'm just going to
tell my hey babe family that I'm upset
and Purge it and I'll feel better and it
worked okay so far it's worked okay at
any moment if it stops working just lean
forward and push this button okay where
is it I was I was looking for it the
other day right here it's at the end
back of a foot
Albany this weekend she came on stage
she said she yeah she said you saw her
at the end yes was she went to her
family too she was with the front no
just a friend yeah uh uh son-in-law so
so the reason why I'm in a bad mood
something that happened today it's like
things you would find almost maybe in
like a fairy tale yes yes so I I I I I
just landed this morning at six a.m on a
red-eye flight from San Diego I was in
Santiago and I and I got to Santiago
yesterday I landed in Santiago at
midnight I had a show in Santiago at 1pm
and then I flew home what 1pm at 1 pm I
performed for the U.S Navy oh oh I
forgot that's right okay and I want to
talk about the US Navy and how great and
salute so like there was a lot like that
yeah but I I so I I take the right so I
was in San Diego for less than 24 hours
and cross-country flight and I fly home
couldn't sleep a second I said well as
soon as I get home I'll sleep come home
treats on the house tree fell over onto
the house uh Violet my the baby daughter
sick hand foot mouth disease my other
daughter dropped a drawer broke
potentially has a broken big toe
um uh then the insurance adjusters and
people coming to the house so I I
haven't slept at all and then and now
it's one of those things where I've been
trying to do my deep breathing I'm
trying to do my deep breathing I
actually truthfully I contemplated
pulling over off the BQE and
masturbating just to get some of them I
understand just to de-stress a little
bit you want to just be put what you
want to do I had a yogurt from a nice
Danish Bakery across the street I said
Danish people are kind people they're
they're sit you know civilized they
don't like to argue maybe a little
Danish yogurt in my body will help so
far nothing's helping but purging it and
just getting it out that was my
motivation to just start complaining I
don't want to be a Debbie Down syndrome
don't worry about that don't worry
that's what we're here for I'm your
sounding board I'll be your therapist
yeah you I can I can kind of I can can
whip you a little bit Yeah verbally sure
yeah I I can't do that though that would
always make me feel worse some people
like this I didn't say I'm your Whipping
Boy I said I'm your sounding board like
I'm here to listen and let you off on
you oh sound off to me got it got it got
okay I misunderstood yeah I wouldn't
want you to do that but honestly some
people do you need that I'm here for you
that's what I appreciate about it I mean
DeRozan would have done that in a second
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah Rosa does it
I think DeRosa does that even when
there's he's had a full night sleep he
does it without asking on the top of his
game yeah he just comes in and just does
it yeah he's on he's on another road
trip he's on a road trip the rose is one
of those guys that acts like he's
divorced when he has no videos right
dad of many kids in a long marriage like
sometimes when he's going into his rants
he you know when we're just talking to
the phone on Mike he's going to start
on his wife and kids and I'm
like I forgot he's single
and it's always like oh man he must have
a tough life at home with the wife or
kids somebody stressing no that man's a
free man with free will that is a
bachelor that does whatever he wants or
whenever he wants and is doing the
career that he wants babe you never know
let me let me tell you so I did a gig
for the U.S Navy okay let me tell you
about about these people those are the
guys in the water they deal with the
water in the water and these are the
guys from San Diego when hits the
fan like these people that I was
performing for they are the first way
they go to war that aircraft carrier I
was on that's the one that goes the USS
I think it's the U.S Lincoln USS Lincoln
something Lincoln but that goes South
China Sea Middle East those that these
are the actual guys you know it's just
not like
these are battle these are kid because
sometimes like you know we got By Us
Fort Hamilton Fort Wandsworth it's great
respect those soldiers but those guys I
don't know that are necessarily going to
war immediately yeah I don't think so
San Diego they're going away they're
ready to be deployed they're ready
they're Navy Seals like they're ready
so the gig was
okay so comedy the the the things that
are hard with comedy are trying to stay
clean when you're not a clean comics
doing shows outside in the middle of the
day yeah daytime outside and and not
talking about sex those are three very
hard things for a comedian to do even if
you're in an enclosed area this show no
can't curse can't talk about sex can't
talk about the government show is
outside 12 O'Clock High Noon 90 degrees
4 000 people standing right standing
only standing and they're standing
walking there's taco trucks surrounding
the stage yeah and they say yeah well I
had asked you why even take the gig and
I think that it's like let me do it let
me get the experience maybe you get
material on it right I said let me do it
let me let me let me get material out of
it let me just I'll feel like a better
person I'll feel like a better comic
after I go up there okay you know they
introduce me you know they had a DJ the
People by the way the person the group
before me they're called steel and wool
country band everybody he was loving it
they were line dancing they were having
you went on afterwards not before they
were having the best time steel and wool
was crushing and they're having the best
time they abruptly stopped and say now
it's time for the comedian me at 12
o'clock people of course rightfully so
start screaming no no I want the music
which I mean these kids are you know
right they're kids like they they just
some of them some of them just got back
from tours in overseas like a week ago
they're like I want I want to dance and
make like just get they want country
music and they want to dance yeah they
don't want to be told about what it's
like today to Puerto Rico no no well
because most of our military especially
in San Diego are Mexican so I changed
all those jokes to Mexico
but but but
I literally I swear to God I'm up there
staying in my content restrictions I'm
eight minutes and 50 seconds into the
show microphone goes out no no
microphones yes no microphone yes no
microphone you want a wireless I had a
wireless uh no I had a wired mic went
out went out I and then so now I'm like
and they're like back up Mike no they
give me the backup mic wireless mic
wasn't charged
so or no batteries also didn't work the
speak what happened was the entire audio
system was out because they had a
generator that was running the the
electricity to the the power to the
stage yeah it it ran out of gas
so I'm trying to get through it like
whatever and then finally a guy comes up
onto stage in the middle of my
performance and says we have it's it's
not gonna work so I now say I have two
options right now I can either but I
gotta pay you because this is a thing or
it's not up to me it's I you know you
have to Force Major yes so I could walk
off after 10 minutes and get paid in
full and leave and kind of like scared
out if I feel like a piece of feel
like a piece of I said I'm gonna
have to scream my set and oh my God I
put the microphone around my neck
and I start screaming my set and I said
you know what I said to them I then I
just was honest I said listen I said
listen
they told me I can't curse I can't talk
about sex I can't talk about the
government I said but you know what
should have went off shits went off the
rails and I just in my head said just
let one rip I said you know what guys
you know because I was like trying to
feel it out I said you know what guys
you know what's interesting to me this
generator just ran out of uh uh the gen
they don't have enough money to put gas
in the generator but they got enough
money to send to Ukraine and they start
going 4
000 people
provided no no yes the entire Navy
there was no like it would happen you
know bro well I mean some of the people
they literally literally I said and then
they went crazy and then they said you
guys mind if I curse and they were like
do it and started going crazy and then I
just said look at you with your
final mustache start exploding no by the
end of the show I swear to God by the
end of the show I had about 20 Sailors
in the front row with their shirts off
doing push-ups going crazy like I
whipped them up like too much no they
the the lady who ran the show was like
you know like wrap it up wrap it up
these guys they're gonna start taking
their service weapons out like
how long did you do another 40 minutes
no yeah with no mic screaming how how I
was just yelling I was like in there
like I did things like I was like played
games with them push-up content yeah you
know like whatever you gotta yeah yeah I
did all I did the best I could materials
not gonna work with no eventually the
crowd started even in the middle of my
set they couldn't hear me so they
started dispersing but I still had like
maybe a hundred but you did what you
needed to do and then some in the
conditions yeah yeah and and what the
one thing I realized though is number
one performing for these kids like
they're kids like yeah I I know like
people that talk crap about the military
we have our right in the country but I
really you should go go be with the
military because you'll think twice
about on our troops when you
see that they're genuinely children like
yeah 18 19 year old kids that have
already done six months in the Middle
East some of them have like killed been
you know killed people their friends
have died and wild and they're just in
the military because they have to get
through school yeah you know they they
had reasons why they have to be and
they're the nicest kids and so thankful
and appreciative for entertainment
because and it literally this event was
for their morale it was for the morale
of the troops that's what it was for
well there you go yeah and and so like
whipping them up and then I just and
then I and then I just started saying
because again they said don't don't rile
them up and don't talk about the
government and I didn't talk about our
government but I just said you know what
man you know who I think can suck it
China and they were like
yeah because like in the military's mind
like that's these are the potential
enemies you know I don't have I don't
know anything about the politics of it
but they were and I thought because I
said I'm gonna get paid either way are
you yes yes because I didn't know if you
looked at the people who booked you and
they were like and you had anything did
you have any reservation moment that if
you went there that they'd be like hey
dude you said you wouldn't do that
here's what actually happened here's
what truthfully really I'm not even
kidding what happened is I said what's
more important than the money whether I
get paid or not I believe I'll get paid
but if I don't because I had to do a
meet and greet before the show to meet
these kids I was like I want to perform
for it like this all they do is listen
to podcasts right because they're on the
ship they that that carecraft carrier
just came back from the South China Sea
so they it takes three weeks to get
there and then three weeks back and
there's no service or they're just using
a podcast so it was like just perform
for them like they were excited they
were like happy you know yeah it was
like awesome you had to curse I I
literally I got I I got some advice from
a guy I know in the military he was like
look I've been to these shows where
sometimes the comics stay within the
guidelines it always sucks he was like
we all like are in potentially going to
war so like we we can handle curses we
want a curse we want we want to be we
want they're Sailors yes literally
cursing like Sailors yeah it's insane
that that was in the contract yeah like
no cussing around the sailors then I
said I said to them they are the only
ones left I said I said there was this
one kid I said I said I'm gonna be look
you got anybody ever have sex on the
boat I said it's beautiful men before
and they said no we can't do it you know
whatever and then like a secular buy one
kid was like I did it no he goes I did
it and then everyone went nuts yeah I
was like I do you did it he was like we
were out to sea and I did it I caught a
I did it
from another
sailor yeah a female right yeah but but
then that but not the girl was like me
too that's it I did it no yeah he just
outed it he said it but he didn't call
it then one kid tells me one kid goes he
was like the only one of the only ones
not dressed in uniform I said why are
you not in uniform he said mental health
I said oh you've taken a leave he goes
yeah I said then why are you on the
Naval Base he was like I don't have
anywhere anywhere else to go I was like
but didn't you take a leave from the
Navy I said why did you take a leave
from the Navy he's like I saw an alien I
saw a spaceship an alien spaceship and
it's freaked me out I said where'd you
see the alien spaceship he was like over
San Diego I was like are you are you on
drugs
but he was fine he was like they didn't
care you were ripping them all right no
no and he was on a mental health he was
being he was sitting there with a in
it's a 90 degrees he had a black coated
sweatshirt on just sitting there just
like looking at me the whole time like
you could tell he's like something's
wrong with him
I was like you you're like a front line
kid yeah that's yeah that's you picked
out and then the Navy Seals man like
seeing some of the Navy Seals like
they're just like like machines like
it's like seeing like a machine with a
heartbeat I went to school with someone
who became a Navy SEAL really yeah and
they got to they probably went through
they have to go through the San Diego
yeah they went to they were Navy SEAL
yeah one time I remember we were out and
we were the large group and he got drunk
and got on a car and stomped the front
windshield oh yeah I believe it of
course you know this podcast sponsored
by better help help there it is folks
better help we both use it
um listen life at times can be tough
when you're dealing with decisions
around career relationships or anything
else therapy helps you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
life so you can move forward with
confidence and excitement we talked
about it on this week's podcast as a
matter of fact one of the leading causes
of stress in people are not being able
to make decisions yes and when you're
going down and you want to make sure
you're going down the right path in life
making the right decisions is part of
that I'm going down nice cause better
hell around
trusting yourself to make decisions that
along with your values like anything the
more you practice it the easier it gets
okay so whether you're dealing with
decisions around career relationships
like you said give better help a try if
you're thinking to start in therapy it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and then switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge go to betterhelp.com hey babe
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe let therapy
be your map with betterhelp dial let me
see your box oh you're talking about my
butcher boxes hell yeah yo you're
wearing them you're wearing them short
shorts I can see that butcher back nice
uh can you scroll up to the top person
because it's your favorite cut from
butcher box uh do you want to know for
real seriously I swear to God I really
want to know pork chop pork chop had it
three nights ago from butcher box
stupendous
word that needs to be used more
religiously and I'm very happy that you
just use that word absolutely and it is
the word that describes butcher box the
best is the meat is stupid
absolutely yeah and it's cheaper than
the grocery store yeah and you won't see
these deals anywhere else and everything
is high quality Meat and seafood you
could trust the grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raise
crate free yeah wild caught Seafood it's
a little right to your doorstep it's
always free shipping yeah okay and of
course they are giving us a deal our
listeners a deal 100 butcher box got
higher quality meat than Magic Mike
right now all you got to do is go to
butcherbox.com hey babe and use the code
hey babe to get salmon for three months
you're gonna get three months of seven
plus twenty dollars off your first order
I mean literally sign me up for three
months of salmon butcherbox.com hey babe
use that code hey babe to claim the deal
I mean three months of salmon you're
gonna be swimming in Salmon
um amazing
yeah well listen if you ever get enough
the opportunity to perform I want to
perform for the military more because
like I feel like it feels good because
honestly like I'm I'll you know speak
for myself I would assume we're both the
same but I'm too much of a to ever
be in the military I can't be in a war
if you gave me a gun I think the first
thing I might do is shoot myself right I
don't know what to do so I figured the
only way that I can helpfully contribute
is boost the morale and make them laugh
and keep them loose they don't hold they
they have water guns right
when you don't go in an aircraft carrier
you ever have I've been on that one
you've been on the Lincoln yeah so you
did so you probably did you did a show
no I I was uh there for Comic-Con and
they had a MGMT played a concert on it
okay so
so yeah yeah right yeah so
so it's it's
a mile long oh yeah it's insane and they
were like and it's crazy because when
these Jets land they can't they have to
land they you know like when you're on a
plane and you like slow down obviously
to like you you know you'll feel
yourself slowing down they have to hit
the Thruster because if they miss
basically what happens is when they land
on the on the aircraft carrier the
aircraft carrier is moving because it
creates its own wind so it needs to be
moving and then there's these four giant
hooks yeah that literally hook on the
back of the plane and stop it like a
rubber band yeah but you can't be
slowing down because if God forbid you
miss one of the hooks which happens you
have to have enough energy enough thrust
to be able to take off again and try
again so you have to just gun it oh and
hook up one of those hooks hits you and
if not you gotta take off wow and he
said you know we got to land that like
you know like like he said it was crazy
like during World War II like guys would
have to do that with like enemies firing
on them right now no enemy has fired on
on one of those uh wow I said to I said
what happens I said what would happen if
like somebody fired one of these things
at uh aircraft carrier he said try it I
was like no I'm not talking about it
[Laughter]
yours yeah I was like you know I I I
have a slingshot
that's so funny so and that what rank is
Popeye Popeye I believe is he's got to
be at least uh a captain he's got to be
up there he's up there yeah yeah he
wasn't wearing that just for fun right
he was he was in the military oh yeah no
every single guy I walked past had a can
of spinach yeah
it's so funny you talked about politics
you talked about uh you cursed yes you
talked about what else was it religion
yeah did you talk about religion yeah I
talked I am I was like I was like so
that was it so the end of the show how
did you sign are you like hey guys
thanks you know but you were yelling
screaming I said I said I said listen
guys you know there's like taco trucks
over there I should go have the taco
trucks I was like uh I did like a
closing joke and I just um you did
material no you haven't I I tried to
weave in and out of material yeah I said
you guys want to see steel and wool I
said you guys want to see steel and wool
there come one they were like yeah I was
like the mics don't work
how did you feel walking off walking off
I felt good because the crowd that was
there all came and wanted to take
pictures and like meet me so you felt
well I did I felt like it wasn't even
necessarily like anything to do with me
it's not like they were like I'm sure
most of them didn't even know who the
hell I was but they were just like so
thankful to like yeah like they for 45
minutes they were like you know we're
just yeah because at any moment those
guys can get can go right all of them
can go I think imagine living like that
I know where and and then you know where
the name as you know like it's this
entire city like it's it's like it's own
ecosystem its own ecosystem and it's not
open to the public and for miles and
miles and miles like you have to go
through like these big Naval barricades
and then it's like they have their whole
world like some guys don't ever leave
that in the face yeah it was one and
then it took me down to the jail you do
not want to go into naval aircraft
carrier jail it is very small very
cramped at the bottom of the ship if
anything ever happened like on that's
the first to fill up with what are your
dead in the cell now let me ask you a
question that jail is there for enemies
so they said basically what would
somebody who would go into jail like
that is if somebody in the Navy was like
say like Turned by the enemy almost like
found out to be a spy or terrorist actor
to have a jail for turncoats yes they
say he said but the guy who took me
around was a great I love this kid he's
a great guy he um he has he he's got a
big bald head he looks like a huge
infant and um he uh he he actually looks
like my daughter he looks like Popeye
yeah it looks like Popeye and he was
saying that in his 10 plus years on the
ship they've never had to put someone in
that jail but that's typically what it's
used for they said now listen if
somebody's like smuggles alcohol on and
gets like banged up drunk or
whatever like they might throw them in
there and let them cool it off and cool
off but he's you know you can't have any
alcohol that's weird okay he said people
you know people you can't stop people
from going into San Diego right right
you know
playing like Battleship like what what
no they well it was interesting some of
them some of them they all have Army
fatigues on so I'm like are you guys in
the Army and then there's all rivalries
like they say the Air Force are
the Army is gay but I was like I thought
the Navy was gay because it's semen well
they're all gay now right yeah
everyone's allowed to have everyone's
gay yeah yeah no no yeah no I mean like
every wait what
what do you mean they they feel like
certain factions of our military are
fully holy gay they said they I was told
by them that I believe it was the Air
Force or Army was gay or the air force
is
because my thought was because there's
F-16 fighter jets on the the thing and I
was like don't you need the Air Force to
fly those they're like no the Navy flies
those I was like what's the point what's
the Air Force for and they were like the
Air Force does more stuff on the ground
I was like but the name's nier right the
Air Force so I was like I I was like so
who does the ground force they were like
the Army I was like but but you just
said the Air Force yeah it's confusing
to me too
so I don't know so they weren't in white
thing white outfits no they were in they
were in battle ready Army because they
actually maybe you'll feel a little let
down by that yeah you know yeah but they
were really um really good kids and uh I
I if you ever get the opportunity to to
meet the military or if you're an
entertainment perform for them I want to
do it again yeah I've always heard that
because it's like you know it's like
doing a college gig which are hard for
comedians but these kids are different
right they're different they're like not
going to be offended yeah they're battle
hardened they're like wanna they
actually wanna laugh yeah we we uh in
every show we invite like most shows we
do even try to invite like Wounded
Warriors and stuff for free like to come
right we give like the the bunch of
tickets to come so I always endocinos
those guys or something else too yeah
like well I saw one guy recently came up
to me and he had uh I guess his arm was
um you know he had the uh what do you
call that like the prosthetic arm yeah
but like a fully functioning one or
whatever oh yeah and and even I think
even a leg I think and this guy guy was
literally like he had jokes for days
sure like I'm sure he does it like he's
he's used to it now and he's come to
terms of maybe he's just humorous
mechanism or he he likes to uh dissing
like um what's the word I'm looking for
when he's like to defuse like any
tension people might be nervous because
like they come to him yeah and this guy
made like within like five minutes he
made like 10 like 15 like well-written
jokes right like they had he had him in
the Arsenal about his apartment like and
I was like yeah man I mean you're
laughing because you want me to laugh
you know yeah what I mean what what can
you do God bless him God bless us all
yeah um and then you got off that issues
drinking off the ship and I got off the
ship and I uh and they gave me uh they
gave they gave me a Philly cheesesteak
which was really good and I said you
know what I don't want to eat the bread
I want to just try to eat keto so I ate
the I ate it with my I ate it with my um
hands and then Jasmine sent me a picture
of the roof damage and I ate the entire
bread
I just said I just ate all the bread and
cheese and onions and then I just was
like and then I walked around San Diego
for about four hours
sat down by the water uh and then got on
got on the flight I walked Straight Out
of Compton on the flight home yeah
that's a good movie good movie yeah
um and then that's uh that's uh uh Ice
Cube's son uh Jackson
good name good name yeah and then I did
I was in Montauk I did mushrooms um all
weekend last weekend in Montauk I went
to Gurney's and I was I was shroomed out
and I and I and I wrote this and I I
remember it because I was also drunk but
um that's when I that's when I uh uh
posted you can only control your output
not your outcome go out and give it your
best Nothing Else Matters I'm on shrooms
I don't know why I said that
um but I I said it of course you were on
shrooms in Montauk at a party spot or
whatever you are because you weren't
with me
but you leave these walls right and you
you just you just become another man but
although you shed this weekend we did
have the dinner though two weeks ago we
did we were we were smoking uh vape pens
yes yes and then but then where that but
now the tree fell through that yeah yeah
and then you gave me actually a bar of
uh for the what'd you think for the
mushroom I didn't do it yet but but
every time I opened my fridge I look at
it and I go it's got to be like soon
soon yeah yeah it's um if you eat the
whole bar you can because I was reading
the proportions on the back so when you
do it do you eat because if you it's I
think it says if you eat the whole thing
it says you can actually like so for me
I and and I don't know I'm new to all
this but I was micro dosing I was
thinking micro dosing little by little
is good but I would always get kind of
like a constant headache I like the way
I feel but I I didn't right so what I
did for this one is I not the bar a kid
who was out there had actual the Caps
yeah and I took 10 of them so I said let
me just really do this one big dose gave
you who who made who said the 10 was a
dose the kid Google I Googled it they
said if you want to go if you want to
really psyched it down because it they
all have different potencies so you can
never really like you got to be real
careful with that
well well see I didn't know that did you
get to a point though
my own I only did mushrooms twice only
one time was good and uh it was but I
got all those effects that they say
You're supposed to get did you get those
I got well what happened was for me is I
didn't see third eye opening I didn't
see things in different colors or
anything I was I was so calm and relaxed
and for some reason my thoughts and my
words I felt the most articulate I've
ever felt in my life like words that I
read and paragraphs that I read in books
that I've been reading that I couldn't
that at that moment I couldn't retain
were like opened up in my head right you
were just on point and scholarly yes yes
it was weird who was so were you talking
someone's ear off about about words and
then I said I must have said that I must
have said that I think I I said that to
the kid who came in the shrooms and he
was like oh I'm gonna write that down I
said well I'm gonna write it down too
okay did you perform him on talk or that
was so fun no it was just for my
birthday okay yeah it was my birthday
out there so we went the kids
uh it was great it's called um all right
oh it's called Driftwood okay Driftwood
Resorts and it's I I always stay there
okay I like that yeah cool I like it I
like Montauk I like we went to um
Scarpetta oh yeah gurneys oh yeah very
good great food yeah great um great food
I had uh three or four desserts
um it's your birthday it was my birthday
you went shorty I went I I've been
deviating from Saturdays for the sweets
I deviated big time from Saturdays or
for the sweets for the past two weeks
but now I'm back on now your boy back on
okay I gotta be back on I know because
because it it just for me I can't I just
like I I signed back into my Instagram
babe you know what's the worst thing a
bad razor and I'm on the road all the
time when I'm on the road and I need to
look good I need to count on a razor to
be good 100 and uh years ago I I learned
about Harry's and now they're a sponsor
on the Pod I think is really cool I
don't know if you got your your uh razor
in the mail with uh the gel the shaving
cream I just used it for the first one
this week yeah for that I was using a
different brand I won't say which yeah
well Harry's blew the doors yeah off of
this other brand dude Jasmine actually
used it first time she has had a
mustache in nine years
a smooth shave shouldn't be rough on
your wallet come on man the starter set
is 13 bucks uh it's what's a 13 value
but just three bucks at harrys.com hey
babe it's a five blade German engineered
razor and you know they know how to
engineer
the handles weighted so it feels like
you're holding something substantial in
your hand the foaming shave gel is a
travel cover scheduled delivery for
refills as low as two bucks that's half
everybody else okay half and they got
creams they got washes they got lotions
that's what it is they made they're made
in their own Factory in Germany that
stay sharp guys who have tried it say
their eight shave is as sharp as their
first Sleek ergonomic weighted handles
that look right in your bathroom and
give you precise control with each swipe
right now you can get a 13 starter set
for just three dollars at harrys.com hey
babe that's
h-a-r-r-y-s.com slash hey Vape for three
dollar Starter Set get your best shave
ever this summer with Harry's razors and
skin care products
all right babe game time this app I've
been telling you about this app I think
you've used it yeah a lot of game time I
mean I'm in full I'm in full I've
actually deleted every other ticketing
app off my phone because game time is
the only one that I use it's the best
the thing that I love about them you can
get tickets to anything you want
concerts sporting event shows the thing
that I love about them the most is the
game time guarantee if you find seats
yes okay if you find seats in the same
section okay and row for less money game
time credit to 110 of the difference for
me that's the selling point it's like so
no matter what I'm gonna win you're
gonna win because absolutely and the
thing that I like about them is uh I
like that you can see an image of your
seat and I also like that once you have
it up and set up it's like two clicks
and you're done and they send the
tickets to your phone so I don't know if
you got you get virtual tickets I do a
lot so when you're on that line and
you're like shuffling through emails to
look for like the ticket it's right on
your phone so many things right yep snag
the tickets without the stress with game
time Time download the game time app
create an account and use hate code hey
babe for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code hey babe for 20 off download
the game time app today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
all right everybody guess what we added
a show in Irvine California September
6th a late show has been added so go get
those tickets everything else is sold
out Portland September 8th is sold out
September 9 Seattle we have limited
tickets if you want to see me in Seattle
go get them Radio City New York City
September 22nd the show is sold out we
potentially might open up some tickets
but I believe it it is fully sold out
September 23rd theater at Madison Square
Garden that's your shop to come see me
in New York City and then September 30th
Las Vegas at the cosmo christycomedy.com
for Tinky Wiki's brand new hour of
material this will be my new hour that
I'm putting out so come see it live yes
hey don't you dare skip this okay this
weekend September 8th I'm at the
Syracuse Funny Bone for the weekend and
then I'm rounding that off in September
going to Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Ohio and Toledo Ohio and
there's more dates on and on through
December uh savocanocomedy.com right now
Syracuse I'll see you this coming
weekend also Sal vulcano official on
YouTube please subscribe uh once a week
starting in two weeks I'm going to be
giving away a prize every single week to
only the people that are subscribed to
my YouTube I'm pulling the winners from
there it could be anything from a prop
from the show free tickets to see me
autographed posters of set visit and
actually if we get to 500 000
subscribers I will pull a winner out of
those subscribers to go to dinner with
me and Joe Gatto so that's that also if
you haven't got it get
shipfacedcruise.com come on the
Impractical Jokers and Eric Andre Cruise
in January 2024 we're almost sold out
check that out everything's available
right now sabolcano comedy.com and we're
making tickets a little more affordable
because I want to reach all of my
audience so if you you know if you're on
a budget check it out this tickets for
you as well
my actual Instagram account for the
first time three days ago I saw how it
felt for an hour easy I said
yeah yeah it was nice for an hour to see
what was happening what was going on I
said oh you know look at this you know
see what that's up to what's add up to
people I haven't seen in a year
Instagram accounts people you forgot
about yeah and I'm like I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go right back off did I tell you
last time I was up up by Montauk I went
to eat lunch
that was it my lady uh her mom and we
were with a couple people and um we uh
we we ordered a lunch and uh sweet girl
came up uh took our order and then she
walked away and then like
40 minutes went by
and nobody brought anything and the
table to our left and to our right were
seated after us finished paid and
already left it's like maybe even more
than 40 minutes did you get anything
like no so we were like we're like
wondering what was going on but nobody
came to us to say anything and I was
like maybe we should say something right
because like what is going on here and
then
so we got we held someone down we're
like hey we we uh we ordered like a long
time ago uh we didn't get anything it
was like a salad you know and they were
like oh let me check hold on they went
back and they came in and they said
something and it was a lie I forget what
they said but um I think they said that
like they put it in it was a problem
with the kitchen but I think they forgot
to put it in okay whatever
so like no problem you know and they'll
bring it out and they brought it out and
then two of the dishes were wrong right
so we were like ah this is lame and then
I didn't see the girl since she took the
order but two other three people came up
today like the owner or like another
waiter or waitress and then after we got
the food and I said oh sorry this is
wrong they brought out something else we
were eating this time is about an hour
and the girl the original waitress comes
over
and she goes excuse me and I turn and
she's fully crying she's fully crying
and she's like I just want to say I am
so sorry like all I want here is for
everyone to enjoy themselves and have a
good meal and I just I I should have
said something and I what happened and
she just thoughts I mean she's she's has
tears coming out in a full and those
restaurants packed the full restaurant
and I just we were looking at her like
oh my God like we don't even know how to
react is that what to say and I was like
please please like don't worry about it
it's okay it's no big deal really I
thought you would have been like give me
my French fries you crazy that's
normally that's that's the cell I know
you
[Laughter]
no I was I was literally Frozen because
it was so uncomfortable and I felt awful
right but I didn't we didn't
say anything bad about a cry and she
went and we didn't even we didn't say
anything we were only nice but she came
over crying and it was like a shock and
all she did was forget to put your order
yeah but she forgot all of them and it
was an hour and then she got it wrong I
I was just like don't worry don't worry
she's like no I'm just sure and she I
know and she described me like please
please
you know don't worry about it don't
worry about it she's like I'm sorry a
tree fell on my house and I couldn't
sleep on the red eye and the microphone
broke in the Navy game sale this won't
let me curve
um so
I said no problem she walked away and
then I had to give like a hundred
percent tip oh of course you didn't have
to but it's it was like yeah but so that
but that's like I mean listen on one
hand you're like this girl really cares
about a job that's a good employee but
on the other hand you're like is she
having a mental health break do we need
to fire this person I don't even we'll
give her leave you know yeah I don't
know I don't know what that was but I
never had that happen my entire life
really I've the only situation I've had
that it's nothing like that we I was out
it was me Jazz I think my father and my
step well maybe my no my father was
there it was me it was me Jazz and my
mom we there was a um uh we ran into a
restaurant in Long Island City and
ordered the food and the way it you know
it was fine and the waiter came back
without like he was in a whatever they
were in black shirt black pants came
back down street clothes said hey guys I
want to let you know I quit I I swear to
God he was like I quit your food's
coming out but I'm not working for this
place anymore and he goes good luck with
the food I swear to God and he said to
him uh uh whoever got like an appetizer
he was like this oh the ceviche he goes
Ceviche is terrible so you guys order it
but it's terrible and then walked away
and then a manager came out gave his
food he's like I'm sorry for that we've
been having some problems with him but
you know this meal is comped and I
remember we got like a cop how was the
ceviche uh I don't remember actually if
I wonder who's throwing shade or warning
you right yeah everybody has something
you know what's weird to me it's like
pretty big things happen in my life
sometimes like that or things that
people would be able to recall every
detail and sometimes I can't I don't
even remember it happening but I'll be
able to recall my new details on very
mundane yeah days yeah but the big
things like I'll go to see a play and be
like I'm so excited to see this play
I've been heard about this play yeah and
then 10 minutes in I'm like I saw this
play already
I saw the play like that's like yeah or
like movies yeah movies I I've seen it
yeah more like I was like wait a minute
I know what's gonna happen yeah yeah
like I saw my I told my dad just the
other day I'm like I'm like Dad it'd be
awesome to go to like see a Yankees
World Series game together just me and
you guys yeah man like you know what we
used to when you're younger and I said
no what do you mean you know like me and
you will go together he goes yeah we've
we've been to them and I was like oh so
something's happening where I'm not
present at all in big moments I got two
for these okay okay first one and I
don't know if I told you this before but
it was uh we were at my my ladies like
family's house whatever and we were
talking and I was at Christmas time or
something and Paul McCartney came up and
I was like oh my God Paul McCartney you
know like who knows how much longer
they'll tour or play you know like you
know just unbelievable and my lady goes
yeah you know we should try to go see
him
and I told her I said what she said we
should try to go see him I said we've
seen Paul McCartney she's like no we
haven't I go no we haven't I said we
went like four years ago in the fourth
row Center I paid the price of a Kia
Sportage to go to it I said we have we
have collectible tickets at home he
played for three hours I cried three
times you were the only person with me
sitting next to me you don't remember
seeing Paul McCartney sing every hit
he's ever had she doesn't she's truly
she swear to God I guess I maybe no she
goes I I don't know was she drinking
that night maybe no no and she was just
like oh okay I guess I guess and I was
like are you nuts bro
like that's that was a lot of money also
it was a like a core memory that is a
corn memory it's important but I guess
not for her it's crazy how it's like it
didn't matter to her I was like
see him right I was like I haven't I
pulled out when he got home the
collector tickets I was like we went we
went and then did she recall
she was like oh okay
you have a tumor I don't know I didn't
another thing I forgot completely you
said if you forgot big things this is a
big thing in my life I forgot all about
it uh I recently got a bunch of old
cassette tapes digitized like you know
those super eight tapes yeah like in the
in the camcorders and stuff yeah and I
got a bunch of those digitized so you
know I could save them for life and one
of the things I sent to this guy to
digitize was I don't know if you
remember this when we were little there
was a Fisher Price video camera yes it
was called like the pxl 2000 yes and you
put in what looked like an audio
cassette tape in there right and it
recorded just on that tape that's it I
remember it I didn't have one but I
remember I had me and my sister both got
it for
um Christmas one year and so we both had
them and this was like I gotta believe
that I was I'm gonna say 12. how much is
that going for because I have that box
300. I have that whole thing that whole
setup brand new in the box Mint
Condition two of them yeah I know when I
was little I kept my toys in the box I
have everything so my
anyway I got that tape digitized now I
only had two of them and I remember what
was on it because I remembered what we
did because once I taped it
to tape again I had to tape over it and
I never wanted to tape over what I did
because I got all the neighborhoods
together and we filmed a wrap video for
Slick Rick's children's story okay and I
know I know all the words
I have it it came out in severely
deteriorated deteriorated quality but
the audio is still there on this
transfer and I totally forgot because
I'm listening and like looking through
like the the like the snow like the
white noise like stuff and I'm like
trying to remember anything and I
remember we planned this whole thing it
was only one shot we had no editing so
we had that much tape and we we planned
it all we ran it and it was one
continuous shot and the song is like a
story and so we acted out the story as
we went around with the camera I was I
remember I was saying I had bat dude
remember those Batman medallions when
Batman one came out like with like
Michael Keaton and and they had these
like Batman with these cheesy ass Batman
and diamonds because the Batman t-shirt
was like the Bart Simpson t-shirt that
year oh yeah okay yeah like
neck medallions like um
kids like that okay that oh that the
yellow one so I'm wearing that kind of
we were wrapping and everything we go
through and I it was like it was it was
the Fourth of July weekend and as I'm
watching it and we're rapping everything
I hear
people screaming and go put them out put
them out I forgot that during that video
someone shot a bottle racket a bottle
rocket at my friend base and he was
running and it hit him in the back his
shirt caught on flight he fell onto the
floor and literally they ran and stomped
it out he had a whole a black hole in
the back of his white Batman teacher
that big can happen right in the middle
of the video they shoot a bottle rocket
out we're still like Fourth of July we
used to do that like we used to like put
the bottle rockets in the end of pipes
yeah and hold them and shoot him at each
other that's good yeah it was like yeah
we didn't do it well after that we
didn't do it what neighborhood was that
Rose bank
and uh dude I totally forgot about it I
remember we did the video but I forgot
and I'm watching it you don't have video
of that it's so it's so grainy but the
audio is there oh you hear it yeah you
hear it and I I got I'll I'll bring it
and you hear like
and you hear like a pop and he was
screaming see you have so many things in
your life that most people are like I
wish I would have did that but you
actually did it the diary the video
cameras of childhood there's so many
things so almost all of us wish we did
that but I got none though I mean I I
don't have any video of me as a kid
yeah but no but that's only from 19
that's only from 1997.
yeah but still yeah to be able to look
back and see your thoughts from 1997 and
be able to almost go back to that day is
amazing yeah I've tried yeah I've been
all fairness it was more like what I did
as opposed to like diary entries yeah
but the one I but isn't that I feel like
a diary is just writing down it could be
anything whatever yeah I I've been
trying to do a diary but I I it doesn't
work yeah a journal I Journal would you
when you would Journal would you do it
at night or in the morning or just
random no no random yeah I try and just
make sure I wrote every day what I did
at night do you read a book at night or
what what's your nighttime routine do
you watch TV do you have a TV in your
room do you read a book I do I I want to
read but because I'm always so tired and
because I have terrible ADHD it's hard
for me to read so as soon as you get as
soon as you get your head on the pillow
you're going to sleep you don't have to
have a routine to get you to sleep I'm
usually pretty tired enough but I have a
TV in the room I'll fall asleep too for
a little bit but with reading I my whole
life I always read very slow and I
didn't retain a lot of information and
it would I would read so slow it would
take me like a couple of minutes to read
a page because I was like reading it and
it wasn't taking and I would always have
to read the same page again right I like
my cue my buddy queue he's like
legitimately a speed reader I don't know
if you know what that is what they can
read like you can read a whole book in
like an hour he reads like a book in a
day really yeah it's crazy or maybe like
two days do we have to practice doing
that did he teach himself
a lot
for his whole life he reads a lot he's
always reading so
he I saw him read he just goes like
he'll be like this is the page and this
is the page he'll go
wow and to turn the page I'm like and he
read every word yeah and I had to be
like literally like I had to put my
favorite book quiz have you ever done
that like give him a book quiz on what
he just read no I see because he could
just he could just be he could just be
doing that in public he's really not no
but we have the only way I would I want
to suggest get him on the next episode
and we quiz him we give him a book quiz
we'll see we'll do it he'll do it yeah
yeah tell him we'll do it I I'll he'll
do that he'll do that but um I realized
uh late in life after the fact it was my
my ADHD doesn't allow me to focus enough
to retain information to read and uh so
when I do read things it really is a
struggle it takes a long time actually
yeah yeah I um I've I for the first time
in the last I've been telling myself for
years start reading Chris you want to
read you want to be you read all the
time no but really the level the the way
I'm doing it now is like reading at
least 10 to 15 pages of a book a day
every day that's what I should probably
do yeah I should probably take 10 pages
and then I will read yes I don't do that
that's what I do that's what I should do
so I have tons of books and I bring a
book up with me with for Good Intentions
every time I go away on the weekends
if you just say like what I did take his
sacrifice an hour of watching TV and
kind of like earn your TV and read and
then I I keep a book by my bed stand by
my bedside at night and then I read in
the morning and then at the very least
I'm like at least you got 10 20 Pages
yeah and then that carries over to like
other things like now I'm writing more
like now I was like all this time I
would be like with our writing with like
you know I would all of course always
write my stand up but like writing
scripts or sketches about my life and
yeah I'm like I would always be back I
just need somebody who knows how to do
that but I'm like why can't I do that
yeah I know how to do that how do you uh
how do you write for stand up do you do
it on do you actually sit down and write
or do you do it on stage no do you put
anything down so you remember it I
listen so I'll listen back what I
typically try to do is I'll do a set and
then I listen back to it almost
immediately either on the drive home or
the next morning in the hotel or the
flight home and then I listen and
typically if I'm listening and
remembering I'm like okay this bin I did
exactly the same I'll fast forward a
little bit and then the things that I
did new were out of character I write
that down and I try to and I'll say sure
I'll write it down and I'll say expand
on that but sometimes I'll say expand on
that joke and that'll take me a year to
finally expand right so not do it so
same but the joke originally
like you know what I mean like ah the
premise yeah like I I can't sit down in
a coffee shop and just write yeah ideas
never come to me that way they're always
walking or driving and then you just
will work it out right then on stage yes
so you have the Nugget of the premise
you'll Riff on it a bit yeah for better
or worse then you take your way and say
that worked that worked right which I
first originally thought like oh this
isn't I don't have any actual talent
this is stupid like anybody can do what
I'm doing this is like really dumb like
I'm not even I'm not I'm not honoring my
craft I'm not honing my craft I'm not
sitting down and writing like all the
great Comics must do and then I listen
to Bill Byrne a podcast say hit my
process of that's exactly what he does
and he's arguably the greatest community
and that's exactly yeah so it's like you
know it we're always writing if you're
listening yeah and even Colin Quinn
who's like a legend at this who's so
prolific he was like listening his
writing too if you're listening back
you're writing yeah if you're practicing
out you're writing so writing doesn't
always mean for a comic pen to the page
yeah author it does right but for a
comic you're performing yeah and it's
also different to listen to your set to
just if you have a tag or to listen to
it but then to I started doing something
now where I listen to it and I sit down
with a paper and pen and I stop it like
and I'm just like almost like I'm
grading it or right like well that stuff
but I never really do that that's really
helpful yeah because you know you know a
lot of times when you have a joke and
you're like or something and you're like
ah it could be better yeah or like I
could punch that up but it could be a
better line here and you forget and you
get on stage and you're on stage you say
it again like I don't like that I should
change that right it just keeps going
when you sit down and you finally just
stop and go I hate these two lines
forever I know they like work I think
they're cheap whatever and then just put
it back in and it's like it it it's so
so helpful to listen I think I think if
you just control like I tweeted on
mushrooms just controlling your output
just doing the work every day then the
outcome doesn't matter as much so for me
that's why I'm like if I'm listening if
I'm reading even if it's even if you
know you're absorbing you're just
absorbing so I'm doing what I have to do
I can't I can't control if the money
comes in I can't control if the people
like it I can't control all right
controls what I do so I try and that
that that helps me I was actually trying
to do that this morning just get out of
my stupid bad mood but it didn't work
but I I have I have throughout the
course of this episode like I've went
from literally to the point of maybe
just being so mad where you're gonna cry
yeah to to
Baseline normal everyday happiness well
we're glad we could do that for you here
today I'm all the way around do you want
to crowdsource some roof repair money
yes should we put up a GoFundMe yes I
would roof repair slash something of
funding for something deviant to do to
the old lady behind you since she won't
yes yeah yes let's put a bunch of
tripping hazards in her driver okay
we'll see what happens that's it all
right I don't know why she's so mad why
do old ladies typically why is it a
stereotype that they're angry why are
old people angry not all of them but why
do why do you think that she's a mean
old lady yeah what is it do you think
but you also hear she's such a sweet old
lady right that's true you know so she
so so I think she's I think I understand
when people when people are older
because if they've had if they if
they've been like that if they had
shitty lives and now it's just like they
just like it just sucks some people just
I think illegally the government should
remove anyone who's over 65 from a house
and put them all in apartments I think
that you shouldn't have to make someone
who's older who's who elderly and old
why isn't elderly it should be olderly I
literally just stumbled into that why do
why do you have to confuse like why do I
have to confuse my kid
and have elderly means old if elderly
yeah she would get it yeah I don't get
it 65 feels a little young to ship him
out though
you could really attack till you're 85.
let's do 75. I just think they should
not have my houses or cars what about
what have you okay what if at 75 you're
you're just like you are now like rules
or rules I think I'll go into an
apartment yeah that the government pays
for where it's like a he doesn't have to
be like a disgusting old folks home but
it's just you have to have an apartment
you can't have more than 600 square feet
to manage let's call it a thousand
square feet okay you can't have more
than a thousand square feet to manage
and you can't have a yard or property
because then because you can get angry
at that younger people are just trying
to do what's best for their family I
think because you're scared and upset
because you have so much property to
manage you take it out on me it's not
fair it makes perfect sense and then I
got to sell the house and move yeah we
gotta ship them out yeah maybe we still
on online patish you know you never know
right like a draft like like not a young
like a not a Navy draft but like an old
people draft like yeah like how old are
you I am maybe they get take a quiz
right and then they don't pass it like
come on get out yeah but I'm flat-footed
um here we go let's see if you can get
these right this is uh my daughter I got
home this morning and the family you
know they were eating breakfast eating
oatmeal and then my my daughter she goes
um okay Daddy she goes what do you call
oatmeal that has to go outside in the
winter
cold meal coat meal
I can put a coat on I was like okay I
couldn't get that one okay what do you
call what do you call oatmeal oat that's
not bad what do you call oatmeal what do
you call oatmeal that's lives on a farm
goat meal oatmeal
called oatmeal what do you call oatmeal
your thought is like any young man at
the table yeah what do you call oatmeal
that goes in the pool
float meal nice is that kind of rice
oatmeal or she said she said I swear to
God my eight-year-old she goes float
meal also would be accepted boat meal
water you should have
what do you call here's the last one
this is a harder one this is
done and I was like impressed okay what
do you call oatmeal that's in front of a
castle
wow oatmeal was a good one that's funny
yeah that's good did you get them all
did you not get them
um I got stumped on Goat meal I just I
was like I was like honey I haven't
slept I can't do this right now and then
she was like what is it and then you
know and then I was like thinking and
you know Jazz was like
oh she was like what is it what animals
on a what animals on a farm and I was
like why am I doing this and shows
adjusters coming and then she was like
goat me out goat meal
and then I said Stone paste and then
you're not laughing and then I swear to
God Violet Violet the two-year-old is
like sitting there eating her oatmeal
and I was like stumped and I said that
like finally said goat meal and she went
oh my
that's perfect timing all right baby
look what we got through it we got to
feel better in a better mood hopefully
you guys got in a better mood I'm sorry
for being Chrissy crabby in the
beginning but now um now things are
better there's a fun light hot it up fun
light-hearted app why the hell not
sometimes you got to do that stuff all
right
hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]